[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and no way home lander is
getting worse and worse and worse the
guy has fully unleashed the more
psychotic side of his personality and
since removing stan edgar as ceo of
vaught it seems like nothing can stop
him but is there a way to take him down
well throughout this video we're going
to be going through all our theories on
what we think is going to be happening
in the show this contains comic spoilers
so if you don't want anything
potentially ruined then i recommend that
you turn off now if you enjoy them
please hit the thumbs up button and also
don't forget to subscribe for videos
like this every day without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into the boys okay so throughout the
series so far we've heard of a weapon
that's capable of taking down homeland
air the boys ventured out to russia in
search of this and after breaking into a
lab to get the rumored bcl red they came
across soldier boy now bcl red is a
compound that contains the bcl2 gene
injecting this into someone can prevent
certain breakdowns in the body and it is
theorized that it can put somebody into
stasis we find this meridian soulja boy
who has been contained for several
summers and winter soldiers
now there's two things that i gather
from what bcl red does in the show and
that is that it puts someone into
hibernation however this stasis could
potentially remove the abilities of a
soup after getting blasted with soulja
boy's chest beam kimiko was left
unconscious and unable to heal the power
of her healing factor was demonstrated
earlier on in the episode when she took
a shot to the face like rynery's mom on
a friday night
[Applause]
now i think this scene was put in place
to set up her healing ability so that
when she lost them later on it was more
impactful huge shout outs to dr debunk
on youtube for commenting on our last
video and saying that he thinks soldier
boy can completely strip a soup of their
powers which i think could be a big
possibility this would mean that he
would be someone who could stop
homelander as he'd level the playing
field and allow him to be taken down
homelander of course did a big rant
about how he was better than everyone
else and him doing this could be setting
up the fact he's gonna be stripped of
his powers this soldier boy storyline is
completely absent in the comics and the
source material has him as someone who
sleeps with homelander which this series
doesn't seem to be doing speaking of
people that aren't in the comics there's
also ryan harry who sucks about as much
as his mum does on a friday night
now the show's had lots of fatherly
relationships throughout it and we've
seen this through billy and his dad
mother's milk and jeanine stan edgar and
victoria and so on and so forth the main
one is of course ryan and homie though
and this is something i think will
become pivotal to the series ryan is
currently under the care of mallory and
the cia but we know that homelander is
still searching for him i think it's
only a matter of time before he gains
enough power to track down the lad and
after ousting edgar out of vote he
probably has enough resources and
intelligence to find him brian of course
has the same powers as his dad including
those eye lasers that homelander
constantly spams may come down to a
choice where he has to kill his real
father in order to save his surrogate
one and billy and i think ryan
definitely has the potential to take out
his dear old dad now it's also possible
that homeland that has another son in
teddy stillwell in the first season he
had a
a bit of a weird relationship with
madeleine and even got jealous over the
boy because he was breastfed
mmm bit weird anyway
milk
oh sorry any uh so homelander ended up
killing madeleine with laser eye surgery
and then billy attempted to blow himself
and hoe me up we had no idea what
happened to teddy except for a little
line about him being dropped off 17
miles away initially this seemed like it
could have been homelander but come the
third season we now know what the more
likely scenario is here he goes to red
river and here he comes across an orphan
named teddy stillwell that has the
ability to teleport i think they could
likely be setting him up as a future
suit and as homelander killed his mother
he'll likely want revenge if he ever
finds this out now we also know there's
going to be a boys spin-off show
centering around some soups in college
so who knows you might even get an older
ryan and teddy feature in this now
there's also the possibility that
victoria will end up being the one who
blows his head but i'm actually not sure
if she's strong enough she clearly fears
for her life and her daughter which is
why she ended up injecting kompanvi into
her victoria is also based on the
character victor veep who ends up
becoming the president in the comics
homeland beheaded him and i actually
think the same thing will probably
happen to vic but there being a bit of
irony to her being the one that loses
her head for once now this plotline
could end up tying into black noir in
the comics he plays a major role and is
actually the one that takes homeland
down after homie killed the president
and invaded the white house black noir
was sent in after him this is something
that we also got a hint towards in the
recent anime show the boy's diabolical
noir is not there to teach you he is
there to watch you make sure you don't
screw up and embarrass the company
and bring you in
if you do so the series also seems like
it's setting up black noire's arrival to
homelander and this has major ties to
the comics in that he was a clone of the
character who was told that his one
purpose in life was to kill the superman
if he ever went off the leash however
homeland is stuck to the rules for
several years and slowly this sent
blackmore insane he'd been robbed of the
meaning of his existence and thus he
started a plot and plan noir dressed up
his homeland there and carried out
several crimes which he photographed and
sent to the character unable to remember
any of these things happening he assumed
that he blacked out and carried them out
because he was crazy however rather than
being remorseful it just emboldened him
more and he ended up going all out noir
killed homelander after revealing the
truth to him which ended my boy's run in
the comics the saddest thing about this
was that homeland realized that he could
have actually been a hero but he'd spent
his last few years being as evil as
possible because of black noise
manipulation from that point butcher
kills noir and he actually ends up
becoming the major villain in the final
arc of the comics unless you count dear
becky but that's more of a diary thing
anyway you don't care now in the show
black noir is completely different and
he is of course not a clone of
homelander instead it seems like he was
severely brain damaged and from this
point out he's likely being controlled
by edgar in season 2 when he went after
butcher we saw that he was very much an
attack dog for the ceo which could be
brought into the show edgar clearly
isn't scared of homelander and he likely
still has black noir in his back pocket
to take him down if it comes to it a
butcher in the show seems like he's
slowly succumbing to compound vis
addiction he's had signs of withdrawal
symptoms and in episode 4 it seems like
he's hooked on the power that it
provides in the comics the boys alter
compound v without any real issues but
here there's far more of an internal
battle early on in the season we also
had homelander visit butcher and though
this might have been a vision it could
in towards what's to come the scene was
very reminiscent of the one on the
brooklyn bridge in the comics in which
they both very much teased towards going
on a collision course with one another i
think this will also be brought into the
show and that the pair will end up
fighting each other at some point very
very soon earlier on we discussed how
ryan could end up taking down his dad in
order to save billy but the roles could
also end up being reversed that's
because butcher might be put in a
position where he has to save ryan
showing that he'd taken compound v would
break the lad's heart but it would be a
necessary move by billy to stop him from
being killed however he'd likely know
that ryan would never forgive him and
he'd have to sacrifice his relationship
with his surrogate son in order to save
the world that's what heroes do though
baby but it might end up putting butcher
on a much darker path in the comics
after the death of homelander he
continued his mission to kill everyone
with compound v inside them and this
included the boys i think that after
homelander dies had he realized no one
should have the power that v provides
and that he'll set out on this mission
for the final few episodes anyway that's
the list of everyone that we think could
kill homelander i call this video
throwing the wall to see what sticks and
until we get the answers i'd love to
hear your thoughts below on what you
think will happen we're running a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of everything everywhere
all at once on the 15th of july and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts and
theories we picked the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now to message me at heavy
spoilers if that's you if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out brighton of the last
episode which will be linked on screen
right now lots of easter eggs in it and
call backs to the comics so if you're
enjoying the show definitely head over
there right after this without the way
thanks for sitting through the video
i've been poor i'll see you next time
take care peace